yeah what can welcome to this video I'll
be doing some cubed sing again on blitz
games and this is a pretty nice matchup
here between two Russian national
champions um grant myself yeah Faust
here run with the handle Faust playing
white here is yarn ipomoea Chi if i
pronounce this halfway correctly he's
Russian Russian champion I think of two
years ago and the black player here the
one with three pawns for the piece is
the ya current Russian champion who just
won the Russian championship zone about
a week ago or something Dmitry under
akin both are 2700 class grandmasters
obviously and yeah here we seem like
trying to make some headway with the
three pounds for the bishop of course
he's the only one who can really try and
yeah he does his best mobilizing the
pawns I think this is critical for white
in the Blitz game it's very critical and
thinking you'd in general the h-bond now
should um decide ok to maybe yeah crying
at this is checkmate I have two may
times yeah nice endgame fried and I hope
we see a longer mad she and this was
just the first or the second game that
they are playing it's a three minute
blitz and we see here an open Sicilian
night off with Bishop e3 yeah now white
is a huge choice yet a syrah remove he
could also play a 3g form and maybe
going for F for Queen every something
like this although this is so entirely
different here white might try to play
on the queenside and get a five maybe
and now trying to use this somewhat
weakened queenside squares Roxy one with
the idea
get the rope to c7 could be an idea okay
it still plays f55 interesting i would
think that II 5 and d5 now should be
okay for black I didn't do it yeah of
course Roxy ADA Sam is a normal-looking
move as well certainly not they're not
better something I just thought if I've
and d5 look nice again now it's playing
this okay d5 it's maybe not possible
because if I was hanging oh he plays it
anyway interesting yeah 95 maybe just
Queen d6 and then he falls out so hang
yeah y divided that yeah like now with
them to bishops should be okay really
yeah but what what are you doing about
the e5 pawn this is of course a question
that black needs to answer now how would
you protect it yeah Bishop t6 as well so
my thought as well yeah probably you
will get the d5 pawn back down at any
given time gam know it gets rather
complicated maybe rulership t for now
and we should have six looks dangerous
for black i would say 94 to come being
on the f6 porn if he takes with the
porno 94 and taking with rook you can
exchange rooks and then take then you've
got an aussie check for con f6
threatened yeah then this is why black
it's um pausing a BTM and seeing if he's
got got anything decent
yeah this looks grim for black black
skin is really compromised now with this
knight on f6 chopped always attacking
age seven if you take h7 now it's hard
to defend queen age three and maybe
Quincy 5c too yo keV it but why the Sun
upon up anyway and this night is so
dominant hard to imagine that white
shouldn't win yeah still need to be a
bit cautious because whites background
is also good week and you cannot easily
push the deep on yeah this is some the
direct try maybe just yeah maybe just
one looks a bit passive but how does
black defenders pieces now rook bh your
pledges Quincy 7i think can also take f7
but Quincy seven should really win a
piece I think yeah no move f 7 lb seven
hang yeah can just take the bishop now
ya think black had a pretty good
position at one point but maybe this
opening of the position was a bit too
yeah but to a steal something not well
prepared check the land of the design
made next move alright so it's um I
think 2-0 in favor of from the current
Russian champion and we've got a
budapest gambit the rare guest at
current Grandmaster practice camp like
got the pawn back but this is often not
the problem of the Budapest you very
often get your porn back
the problem often is that the structure
that arises and this it's exactly the
structure here that we have in this game
sometimes a bit problematic because some
yeah white enjoy some space advantage
and 95 moves but he may be yeah okay six
this is a fun idea trying to use this
rook on g6 or h6 and this can can really
get down get really dangerous in a wide
yeah this is very very direct jazz
coming for h2 but um yeah the c8 bishop
is really the problem this piece is not
playing and the a7 Bishop can't be a
good piece but only a firm like managers
to get rid of the c5 porn and this is
what he's trying now provoke wide into
taking yeah and now that you should one
day seven is really a good piece
attacking the e3 pawn yeah I rather like
black now it looks our looks decent III
is some point of attack and it's not
them obvious how why should make
anything off the d6 on the d6 for looks
weak but it is nicely protected also by
this age six rook yeah now black mighty
intake III yeah why not maybe you have
something yeah I didn't take it he could
have just taken I think I'm unless
there's some some trigger point that I'm
that I'm really missing now why it keeps
the pawn
kierra Sheard chief is a bit of a weird
move but yeah black cannot take 94 wood
for Queen yeah this is well-liked
retrieved lc8 was somewhat of a problem
maybe black can take now I play rook age
36 to pile up on the upon could be an
ATM just take it on g4 I don't really
see how ok it's got a completely
different idea and he wants to play and
I'm not sure really d5 maybe t5 fixing
the e porn I'm not quite sure about this
move not that I'm terribly suspicious of
it I'm just not getting the idea really
maybe really d5 ok the knight on c6
wasn't doing so much this is e 5 d 4 B 4
square they are controlled by pawns and
white somehow doesn't move hope it's not
a disconnect enter this video will get
the very short it gathers something
wrong here he cannot thank so long yeah
would be a bit of a shame it's an
interesting position below maybe around
equal if white retreats to f3 maybe
certainly some technical glitch yeah
it's a disconnect unfortunately okay now
he's his bag and they didn't lose much
time okay that's cool so we got a
continuation of this game yeah so black
gum tries to play against you three and
yeah white can try to make some pressure
on d5 bishop f3 maybe they've got a very
very bad connection here yeah covering
the d5 pawn and then what black needs a
sum to find some useful role for SC 8
bishop this Bishop is not doing much
Bishop f5 maybe but you could could just
take me to a high yeah so black one upon
but maybe our Bishop f5 are you missed
that you can just take it Queen us
hanging on d3 but Knight f6 also hmm
maybe this isn't clear at all okay it's
still ddd pawn but it's not not winning
immediately or something
I think he can take you can take rupee
for threatening rupee I'd made I had a
plane this much quicker than it looks
like because of this huge like I hope
this will get fixed so that we can
really see this match in when the yeah
with the time actually spent that play
much quicker than it looks like yeah
black doesn't them immediately we gained
the exchange try to improve pieces first
Wow very nice transformation Queen yeah
maybe blacken can do something now but
down again you cannot get to the a porn
yeah I think this is rather drawers oh
the size oops blacks going for the meat
rook h2 mate very tricky Jack yeah of
course it's raw but not quite sure what
was happening yeah okay they should just
agree on a draw in your on yeah they try
to offer but it's hard to accept simply
because of the lack of time yeah I hope
this some connection lack issue will get
better it's a bit a bit strange to to
see the clock jumping back exam so on
yeah drawn their last game and now we
have a pony on nip ami achi on or foster
as he's caught on as he playing the yeah
i think it's called the Larson for
Bronstein last variation of the
caro-kann with gtx f6d think this is
actually a quite underestimated opening
it's a very much playable for black you
don't see it often on the grand master
level because um yeah naturally
grandmasters a bit suspicious about
blacks pawn structure and this is
certainly a yeah correct assumption that
like is running some risks here but it's
a quite interesting it leads to very
young yeah unconventional position types
with the some slightly young Kruger pawn
structure but it's a good weapon if you
are want to have an unbalanced game that
you are trying to win then this is the
certainly the best way to do it within
the caro-kann opening you will get much
more interesting chances than with
Bishop f5 or 97 yes we see here a black
hand sacrifice the pawn with e 5 d takes
d5 and 95 and yeah 93 maybe it's just a
self pin mmm that sure maybe can play 93
and play a king f-111 tween f5 I know it
looks it looks quite shaky for black Oh
immediately the second exchange okay try
to to catch the rook now it doesn't have
any squares King you to is the idea okay
yeah we transposed into an endgame
quickly well check and its material
equality but like seems to have the
initiative now king d to Bishop age 6
and this gets ugly I think bishop age 6
king d 1 and now maybe look a five or a
b5 something like this and wide will not
be able to defend the pond yeah black
had a very
active position I mean maybe this was
awesome a draw or something if you move
to go with white place the exact moves
but this sum is some very difficult to
play now with the a porn is getting lost
and the H porn is sound not dangerous
yet so why does I think pretty much
busted I'm not sure what you should play
really
I know maybe f3 or something f3 okay to
ping up to but it's a pretty much lost I
think with good technical blade black
shut down windows rather easily Roque to
and just rope a1 threatened and I know
what why should should do to defuse dead
yeah i know i don't see you move really
yeah bishop t to see three you can try
now yeah this is reasonable yeah okay
the h-bond you can hope for the h1 of
course but them objectively I think it's
just over who all right so much for
reasonable like just blunt blend at this
this bishop and I know black will get
lots of pawns for all this but it's not
not clear on 92 now yeah and the rook I
don't know black group has no place to
go and the age pawn is maybe I'm up but
you can play rogue age to write my g3
King e5 I think you could play this just
see 20 now takes 93 this should win
really black ass to quit now that's
that's losing oh this was a weird move
rock age too well this is rather easy to
see that white promotes
yeah so worried when r is a very up and
down game where both players were
winning really at some point yeah sorry
for the water noises once in a while I
just need to sip some water it's still
unbelievably hot am all right we've got
a Carrack on again advanced variation
and this is a weird mix IAM with c5 yeah
why played this age 4g form kind of
stuff where you get a huge space
advantage on the Kings side but you
don't develop anything yeah for more on
this you can also look at my channel i
did about I know about 10 days ago maybe
two weeks ago I not sure um i did a
video on absolute brilliant game played
by other musli took the top slovenian
player number two women play in the
world and evil tatarskiy of israel they
played a fantastic fantastic game and i
did a video on that look at my channel
it's also the same line with G forward
and age for all right so here in this
game white played this rather strangely
with short castles a black managed to
play age 5 I know yeah I think what
might need to play g5 and then you've
got the yeah the kingside closed and
you've got this week at five square I
think white should place you for no or
something to get something going on the
long diagonal if you if you play
something passive I don't know then
black will most most likely get a very
strong position yeah yeah I think this
was pretty much the only move to get
some play in the center going
yeah baby 94 as an idea now ID 4p should
be seven or white good yeah maybe what
could also try to get the point back
with Queen a 40 no this is so there is a
discovery Nazi five maybe queen e to ya
on 94 it's a bit like um yeah you need
to need to get some swindling joins the
CM and did some bit of a time delay oops
just got a chance check message popping
up yeah maybe this is some the same
issue with the connection that we had
before let's help um this will will be
fixed
can't believe a let down that they have
there's some connection issues yeah now
we are we're back again yeah what what
enters the end has a pawn on d6 now
still it's not so clear what them what
why truly M has foiled his son is Pawn
deficit and that was still quite
suspicious about White's King position
it's not them problem at the moment but
in the long run White's King might be it
might be the problem just imagine black
castle in Bishop g4 and then the h4 porn
is terribly weak this is also the
rationale behind you five yeah maybe
just castles now yeah OB should be six
you can try to cover this bone even snow
it's not necessary to give it away yeah
but this is straightforward Quincy fry
also have maybe then Bishop berm e6 but
i liked also just Bishop g4 try to win
the th for porn and get at white skin
you have tried to get to a discovery now
nitey form while very quick um
transformation going on Queen h1 oh this
looks nice what does black do with snide
if he goes down and Bishop g4 this is a
really annoying pin when the dip on my
dismay be good now queen age 6 ah Quin
h6 but this is just check that's just
the check maybe this was was too quickly
that he took out at five yeah Queenie
rh6 is really just a check not shown
Jack yeah 3 just prevents I'm Quincy for
check ya black ass um I know still needs
to play very accurately the deep on is a
problem and now maybe ripped it or
something you should meet with the rogue
age 20 gauge to looks a tricky how do
you how do you cover that maybe this is
still okay rook age to its not
threatening made maybe root g two or
something you have six was really the
only move I think yeah the Sun like a
certainly annoying not much we can do
about that okay just just took it oh no
d7d 7 trance Queen g7 made over Queen g7
is made this was just check maeda go in
g7 black resigns yeah like who couldn't
do anything
all right here we go again I hope you
don't mind them connection issues no
it's something nothing human I or
anybody else could do something but all
right we've got a funny French here with
a 6-h a 6 h-6 and they're just playing
this to to make me pronounce this h 6 &
a 6 all right so the thing is some yeah
it says suddenly yeah they were just
having some fun here but really am this
this moves are much more useful for
black curiously because h6 prevents a
possible Bishop g5 okay this is not
relevant anymore because wifey and
shadow at a 6 gives you a nice retreat
square for the bishop yeah well in the
meantime white has established a pretty
nice some controller of the default
square so why should be am really okay
on black am I know the normal move would
be something like 26 or 27 but then why
would capture on f6 so you cannot really
move the Queen and if you cannot move
the Queen it's a bit difficult to
connect your looks you can play a rook
see age and to delay all this for one
move but it's not them clear what this
move really am accomplishes
maybe blacken can try something like I
know 94 something try to open the
position form for porn FY takes it yeah
black as one of his connection thanks
again I can while this is going on can
check weekly if there are some other
games are nothing compare ibly
interesting are they they they drew this
yeah I guess some the connection issues
really am made them make them quit here
alright i hope you enjoyed it anyway
you've got to have now offer blitz
action of the of two russian champions
I'm unfortunately the connection was a
little bit of a spoiler but it was an
interesting chest to watch I guess yeah
thanks for watching the video I'll we do
i do or more of these if they are
interesting games happening